Speaker 1: The moral compass of the Republican
Party could not possibly be better illuminated
than by Matt Gaetz interviewing George Santos
slash Anthony devoted to slash Anthony Santos
slash George Divider, whatever name you know him
by. I'm talking about the liar who was elected
to Congress. He appeared on, I guess, Matt Gaetz
show. I didn't even know Matt Gaetz had a show,
but I guess he does on Real America's Voice. And
the interview is like nothing I have ever seen. I
don't know who thought this was a good idea. The
pressure is building on George Anthony Santos,
devoted there to resign. I don't know
that this interview is going to save him,
but you have to see this. Here is George
Santos saying he has lived an honest life.
Speaker 2: I've worked my entire life. I've
lived an honest life. I've never been accused,
pursued of anything bad doing that's untrue.
Speaker 1: He has actually been accused of
crimes in Brazil already and there are multiple
criminal investigations. But that that's a lie.
Speaker 2: You know.
Speaker 1: If he's lying
about not lying right now before your very.
Speaker 2: Eyes, it's my it's the equity
of my hard working self. And I invested
inside of me, like I said, didn't come.
Speaker 1: From he invested inside
of himself deep, deep inside of
himself. And he found that he is an honest man.
Speaker 2: Burisma. It didn't come from Ukraine,
Russia, China. Unlike some folks that we
all know that get money from those sources.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Okay, So then Matt Gates asks
him, where did your campaign funding come from?
And he again repeats this cute little line.
Speaker 2: One of the principal critiques
I've heard is that a lot of money was
donated to your campaign by you. 700,000,
I believe. Where did it come from? Well,
I'll tell you where it didn't come from. It
didn't come from China, Ukraine or Burisma. How
about that? Well, yeah, that that is an answer.
Speaker 1: That is not actually an answer. We
finally figured out the funding actually came from
what was that country Trump made up? Nambia. It's
not an answer. And he is being dis. This interview
is to prove how honest he is and he can't stop
lying or or obscuring the truth during this actual
interview. Here is another moment during which
Gates says, Listen, sure, you embellished your
resume, but everybody in Congress has embellished
their resumes. We'd have no one in Congress if
embellishing your resume got you kicked out.
Speaker 2: You have admitted embellishing your
resume. You've acknowledged it. You've
apologized for it. Some have said that
you shouldn't be seated on committees for it.
I would offer that if we didn't see people on
committees who embellished their resume running
for Congress, we probably wouldn't be able to
make a quorum in any of those committees.
Speaker 1: Other people embellish,
so everything's fine.
Speaker 2: Do you do you now have a sense of the
committees you want to serve on the type of work
you want to do? I came to D.C. without really any
preconceived notions of what committees to serve.
Speaker 1: He came to D.C. without
any preconceived notion about
what the hell the job entails.
Speaker 2: Whether what I can give to the
American people, whatever committee I'm given,
whether it's, I don't know, science and technology
or education and labor or whatever committee is
thrown my way. I will deliver 110% because that's
what I know how to do. I'm going to outwork any of
the pundits and talking head pundits.
Speaker 1: The word is pundits,
pundits. Come on, dude, that.
Speaker 2: Are out there saying
that I should resign, that I'm unfit
for office. The reality is and the the
the the case in point here being is I'm a
workhorse. I work my whole life. I'm the
kid who came from a basement apartment.
You weren't supposed to win this seat.
I was not supposed to win the seat. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So, Matt, I don't know how Matt
Gaetz ended up doing this rehabilitation attempt
of George Santos. Anthony Older. And on the issue
of resignation. Here is what Santos had to say.
Speaker 2: I wish, well, all of their opinions,
but I was elected by 142,000 people until those
742,000 people tell me they don't want me. We'll
find out in two years. What are those hundred
and 42,000 people deserve in a representative
leadership? Somebody who's going to come here
and fight and not get involved with the media
nonsense that we're seeing take place. Right.
Speaker 1: Nonsense. Now, here's the problem.
The 142,000 people voted for a person that doesn't
exist. And what I mean by that is they voted for
a fictional character who was a volleyball star
at Baruch College, who worked in high finance,
who had degrees that he doesn't really have,
who's Jewish in a. And the reason it's relevant
is it's a it's a district with a significant
Jewish population. And he told stories about
his Judaism. It they voted for someone that
doesn't exist. And so to say well, they now
don't get a say until two years from now because
they already voted for him. They voted for someone
who is not the person actually representing them.
So Gates is now sucked into it. We don't know what
exactly is behind Gates doing this interview.
But what is stunning is that these are softball
interviews. These are meant to be interviews
so easy that they make him look prepared and
honest and qualified and forthcoming and all these
things. He obviously and brazenly continues to lie
in interviews designed to be easy for him to at
least pretend to be an honest person. Let's hope
that is gone by Monday, although anything could
happen. Make sure you're subscribed to the YouTube
channel. We are pushing for 2 million YouTube
subscribers this year. It is early on in the year
and YouTube.com slash The David Pakman Show is the
place to hit that subscribe button. Doesn't change
anything. Doesn't cost anything. You're just
saying I like what you're doing. YouTube Recommend
this stuff to more people. That's essentially
what you're saying. I'll give you an update
on the progress towards 2 million probably late
next week. The David Pakman show is, of course,
funded by our viewers and listeners through the
membership program. If you think maybe this is a
thing that we want to see continue. You can sign
up at join Packman dot com. We'll give you instant
access to the world famous bonus show every day
for our members. You'll also get commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show every weekday,
made available hours before the show is published
to everybody else. All really great things. And
it's cheap, folks. It's very cheap. You can go
to join Packman dot com. Use the code, please.
No more Trump. Please no more Trump. Say it in
your head that way when you type it in and you'll
get a discount and it'll be a beautiful thing.